hello everyone
and thanks for joining over the period
of last year
we have been on a mission to help our
customers get the most out of their
google cloud investments this has taken
the form of consolidating some of the
best practices
on gcp as well as helping customers
identify
potential area improvements within their
people
process and culture while operating in
club
my name is patik sharma and i work in
google's professional services
with me joining here is scott from openx
today we will be reviewing a few key
areas
that we have had the pleasure of
investigating while working directly
with our most complex customers as they
usher
in the next generation of applications
features
and customer experiences
we will be discussing the cloud
landscape
especially the mind shift that needs to
occur when going from predictable
capex model to variable
cloud-based op-exponent to double-click
there are some cultural changes that
needs to occur
before you realize the true value of
cloud
next up we will be discussing cost
optimization recommendations
that have come up frequently been
reviewing the customer cost journey
over the last year later in the
presentation
we will have the opportunity to hear
from one of our favorite
black belt customer openx who is very
well versed in cost optimization as a
practice
scott will tell us a bit about their
experience on how they optimize their
cost on google cloud
so let's get started putting together
the best
and brightest that google has offered to
research in this mission
we haven't spent considerable amount of
time
effort sweat and sometimes tears
to present this very astonishing
conclusion when it comes to cloud cost
and that is no customer wants to spend
more than they need to
on their cloud investment
from the field we have seen customers
migrate their in-house applications
onto cloud infrastructure to unlock cost
savings
however as reality surfaces the savings
that were promised
doesn't really materialize and we wanted
to know why that is
as we dive deeper we found that the very
feature that makes cloud a
shining opportunity to reduce it cost
could end up being more expensive if not
leveraged appropriately
for example due to on-demand and elastic
nature of cloud
procurement is now pushed to the edge
engineers can now spend company money by
spending resources
without traditional finance approval
due to this sometimes it's easier to see
an increase in cost
but difficult to pinpoint where exactly
it is coming from
the variable opex model of cloud with
literally thousands of cost
line items and 100 more popping every
quarter
doesn't help either a common notion we
see
is that cloud cost is not predictable
so we need a framework that is well
understood by
finance who is trying to understand the
variable of
x model by engineers that has to
consider
cost as a matrix just like reliability
and security of the application
and by management that looks at the
value created by the cloud
than just the number of dollars spent
as we discussed more and more we
realized some of the things we take for
granted in our experience
might not be immediately apparent to
someone who has decided to begin their
cloud journey
that brings us to why do we care being
in professional services
we align ourselves with our customers
initiatives
to build deeper trust and long-term
relationship
turns out as for the research 73 percent
of
organization plan to optimize their
cloud spend
making it top initiative for the fourth
year
in a row only to drop our eyes this year
due to the global pandemic so we want to
help you
even if it means you spending less with
us
all right so let's begin the journey
starting with the goal in mind
we have seen customers take advantage of
cloud to launch faster go to market
strategy
enable themselves to innovate quickly
and last but not the least
make customer happier by serving them
during their constantly changing needs
and we see that customer realize that
it's not just about spending less
but it's actually making more by
realizing the true value of club
so then the question is how do you
achieve
all your goals while being efficient in
what you do
well for one understanding that cost
is more than just a call set up
our most sophisticated customers aren't
fixated on specific cost cutting numbers
but they are asking variety of questions
to improve
their overall fitness what are we
providing to our customers
is it a product a service or i will take
an example for instance
machine learning powered memes that are
really fun
i will call it generator 2000
how much does it cost me to provide that
and only that thing
you're looking at cost per service as it
makes sense for the business
going back to my example i'm looking at
all the cloud infrastructure cost that
goes into creating memes
and delivering it through various social
media platforms
lastly how can i optimize all the
correlated spend
per unit create and that brings us to
optimizing at all layers
that makes up the circles
ultimately we see conversation gearing
towards
unit economies in my example
100 of my cloud spend is generating 1
000 means
and 10 000 impressions overall
generating a revenue of 200
and a happiness score of 10 on 10
so now rather than looking at my clout
cost i'm looking at average
cost per meal along with the happiness
code
because that's the true value for my
business
so my goal is to reduce the per unit
cost
so where do we start well first up
it's vital to know where your cost is
coming from
once you know what makes up your cost
the next step
is to optimize so let's look at the
equation for cloud cost
it is resources used multiplied by
the rate paid for the resource so
optimization ultimately comes down to
efficiency in your usage and pricing
let's look at all the tools available to
you to enhance the visibility and
governance
at all layers we will break this down
into three areas
for predictable cloud spend visibility
accountability and control
within visibility you have built in
reports
cost breakdown and cost table to provide
all the information you need
in terms of usage and cost
for more customized views we often see
customers use
raw billing data by enabling bigquery
export
to slice and dice the information as it
makes sense for the business
we recommend running on bigquery billing
export for historical analysis
and trends
for accountability resource hierarchy
and labeling are extremely powerful ways
to allocate cost per business unit
service cost control group or really
anything you want it to be
this should be standardized and enforced
systematically
with this tool you should be able to
identify any and
all cost that makes up your service it
doesn't matter if you are a startup
spending thousands or multinational
cooperation spending millions per month
again you don't want everyone to see
your organization cost
so google cloud provides granular
permissioning
that fits your needs
moving on to controlling your cost our
advanced customers
identifies the slightest leak in their
cloud cost
by using budget and alerting feature
not only that if they suddenly see a
spike of cost coming from a
non-production environment
customer take automated action to
identify
and rectify the cause you also have the
ability to be proactive
and get alerted on the forecasted
increase of cost
versus once the damage is done
and lastly you have quotas that can help
throttle or cap your cause to prevent
bulging weapons
one thing i will leave you with on this
slide is
don't wait for the traditional monthly
or quarterly review of cost we have seen
successful customers review their cost
as frequently as daily
all right so let's take a look at
recommendations that have
come up frequently but before we jump
there
our advanced customers knows when to
stop the train
to make changes that can help them run
leaner
it is important to understand what is
the potential savings
and level of effort required to optimize
anything
this will help you prioritize your
recommendations
so rather than saying hey we can save
some money by moving
all this memes to coder storage as they
are not
accessed frequently the conversation now
shift to
not moving to colder tier can cost us
100 000 this month
but will take two weeks of engineering
effort to implement this
the better optics you have the more
accurately you can pinpoint
potential savings and relative effort
now prioritizing recommendation is
important because there are hundreds of
ways you can run linear
some of which are shown here
some easier to implement like committed
use discounts which gives you
up to 57 discount for your always on
workload or getting rid of ideal cloud
resources
that doesn't provide any business value
that's 100 discount right
there some recommendations are going to
be architecture aware
like auto scaling to scale the resources
up and down
based on user activity or the use of
preemptable vms
for stateless workload which gives you
up to 80
scan lastly there are some
recommendations that are going to be
game changer
especially for our heavy users like
storage lifecycle management and
bigquery platform reservations
i would love to go through each one of
these into great details
on when to use one versus the other but
unfortunately we are tied on time here
the presentation will be made available
to you so you have the ability to dive
deeper
while not on i will certainly go through
some recommendations that are provided
by active assist
if you haven't heard of activeassist it
is unlocking google magic
across your cloud deployment
we are going to use our specialities
around data analytics
and machine learning to provide you
recommendations
based on your usage let's review
resource optimization first
we understand for small and large
organization alike
it's easy to spin up resources and
forget about it
so in this case active assist will
surface
ideal instances and disks to you
if it doesn't provide any business value
you can quickly optimize your cloud cost
by turning it off or just deleting them
not only ident instances but over
provisioning vms is a very common
runaway cost
active assist will surface these
opportunities
and suggest right sizing to further
reduce
your cost when we looked at couple of
examples of resource optimization
let's optimize the rate you pay for
cloud resources
you can now easily see your always on
workload that can be benefited by
committed useless scans
no need to guess what you're saving is
going to be because active assist
will do all the heavy lifting for you
and provide you an easy to understand
actionable recommendations
last but not the least for heavy users
of bigquery
active assist will recommend best
billing model
based on your usage
in addition to cost optimization it can
also help your infrastructure to be more
reliable
secure and perform but there are dozens
check available today we are working on
more
not every recommendation is going to be
impactful for you
some will be good means others will be
transformative
we have seen successful examples of many
customers
optimizing their total cost of ownership
by leveraging google managed services
as well as serverless offering to
offload
all the operational overhead and allow
you to focus on things
that matters to your business this
pandemic
will force business to reimagine ways
to operate with efficiency at all layers
i believe the issue is not so much in
understanding cloud technology
but it is the standardization of process
and shifting culture that is required in
realizing the true value of cloud
now because there are so many moving
parts it's not one person's job anymore
you need a team some decisions
are best centralized like purchasing
committed use discounts
or standardizing cost allocation
strategy whereas others
are more effective when decentralized
like refactoring your application
and right sizing because the application
owner knows
what's best given their current
architecture
no matter what you decide to improve
always define
metric set target goals and measure
often
to track your progress for example
for my application meme generator 2000
i want committed use discount coverage
and utilization
to be above 90 that's my target
avoid going from zero to here
start slow get real-time feedback
and a-trip over time in industry
standard terms
that's learning to crawl and walk first
before you run
i mentioned real time feedback which is
very critical element
for creating a cost conscious culture
as it can help you course correct sooner
think of prius effect it drives
better behaviors we have also seen
customers gainify the impact
which gets everyone excited in reaching
a shared goal
a quick plug check out our white paper
and other assets
for comprehensive view on cost
optimization
here are some quick wins we have seen
across multiple customers
while helping them over the period of
last year
now i would like to hand it over to
scott from openx
for their journey
thank you pithik hi my name is scott
snell
and i've been working with openx on our
google cloud migration
openx is a leader in programmatic
advertising
and we operate one of the world's
largest ad exchanges
we reach nearly a billion consumers and
we work with more than 30 000
advertisers
across every screen and device
my focus has been on cloud cost
management and cost optimization
thank you all for joining i'm excited to
share some of the cost optimization
learnings
from openx
here is our agenda i'll briefly cover
the challenges for openx
in moving to gcp i'll share how we
prioritize things early on
from a governance and cost management
perspective
next i'll cover our approach to cost
visibility
and share a number of examples of how we
were able to implement various cost
optimizations
we'll finish up with a review of lessons
learned
so the challenge was how to migrate 15
million lines of code
from six data centers worldwide in six
months
openx consumes a significant amount of
compute network
and storage resources and we process
trillions of events per day
in terms of migrating to gcp the
engineering teams did all of the heavy
lifting
and did a fantastic job and the
migration was a success
but early on in the migration effort we
needed to organize how we were going to
get started
so let's talk about that
at the beginning of the project paul
ryan rcto
laid out a high-level cloud migration
roadmap
we started with a focus on governance
whereby we set out to establish controls
around product ownership cost
responsibility
roles and budgets and resource
management
including folder organization project
naming conventions
and required project labels and skew
labels
from that foundation we could focus on
cost visibility
and ultimately on cost optimization
let's first talk about cost visibility
our cost visibility efforts have helped
us understand
what we are spending money on sliced on
a variety of dimensions
for example by project by service
by region and by label to name just a
few dimensions
in addition to aggregate cost visibility
we were focusing on per unit
cost metrics also
we prioritize cost visibility around
usage type
namely preemptable on-demand and
committed use
and we turned on gke usage metering to
measure our kubernetes costs by app
by cluster and region so how do we set
up our cost reporting framework
for some gcp customers the gcp console
may provide a good start to cost
reporting
early on we turned on the billing data
export
which is highly recommended and started
to integrate various data sources
into our recording framework we use data
studio
and bigquery for the majority of our
cost reporting
one of our key metrics is how many ad
requests
do we receive each day and what does it
cost us to process each one
we did this by integrating our gcp
billing data
with our openx performance data this
enabled us to get insights into per unit
costs
as well as gross margin performance
in terms of frequency of reporting we
look at cost reporting daily
and we send out a cost summary email
each day to various teams
now that i've touched on how we set
things up
from a governance cost visibility and
reporting standpoint
we will turn our attention to cost
optimization
this grid represents various cost
optimizations in terms of complexity of
the work
relative to the expected cost saving
benefits
also we have organized the optimizations
into four buckets
usage optimization pricing efficiency
waste reduction and refactoring
we are working on or have completed work
on all of the above
overall we have completed more than 30
significant cloud cost
optimizations i'll share some examples
in the following slides
first i'll share two examples of usage
optimizations
the first usage optimization example is
around saving money on egress
we saw that we were spending a lot of
money on egress between zones
which is called inter zone egress in our
regional clusters
see the orange bars on this chart by
shifting to multi-zonal clusters
we were able to reduce enter zone egress
costs to zero
without impacting other egress costs
the second usage optimization example is
around changing the machine shape
to better match utilization of cpu and
ram
by evaluating resource utilization
within a specific project
we found that we were fully utilizing
memory but under utilizing cpu
see the purple bars by changing the
machine shape
we were able to reduce costs by 25
within this project
the last two examples were about usage
optimization
in the next few examples we'll cover
pricing efficiency
finding the best price solution for your
work
the first pricing efficiency example and
the most important
is around leveraging discounted compute
rates for preemptable machines
and implementing committed use discounts
the red line represents on-demand
compute vcpus
you can see a nice drop-off in our
on-demand usage over time
running more services on preemptable
machines the gold line
had a very dramatic cost reduction
also note that some refactoring may be
required to run preemptable
the blue line represents our increased
three-year commitment
this change also led to a significant
cost reduction
the combination of preemptable machines
and committed use discounts
dramatically reduced our costs
the second pricing efficiency example is
around flat rate pricing for bigquery
we are a heavy user of bigquery both for
storage
and for query we found that our
on-demand analysis costs were very spiky
and we had days where we spent way more
than expected
by committing to flat rate pricing we
were able to better control our costs
the downside is that some queries may
take longer to run
if capacity demands exceeded committed
capacity
in our case our queries were primarily
for analysis purposes
so we were fine making a performance
trade-off
as a result our on-demand cost dropped
and we attained a more stable cost for
bigquery
the third and final prices pricing
efficiency example
is around reducing storage costs by
choosing the most cost-effective storage
class
we reduce storage costs by 50
by shifting from regional storage the
blue bars
to a blend of cold line and near line
storage
also while we are on the subject of
storage
we've done a lot of work with data
retention policy changes
a form of waste reduction and these have
also had a big cost saving
impact so what kind of cost impact did
these and other optimizations have
i mentioned earlier that one of our key
areas of focus was on optimizing our per
unit costs
one important cost metric that we track
is cost per ad request
this chart shows our cost per ad request
over time
through a combination of usage
optimization
pricing efficiency waste reduction
and a fair amount of refactoring we have
reduced our per unit costs by more than
60
since september of last year this is all
during a time of increased ad unit
growth
now we'll wrap up with some lessons
learned
here are some key takeaways from our
experience optimizing costs in gcp
cost management and optimization is not
a one-person job
your success will depend on good
teamwork across the organization
it might be boring work but an early
focus on
governance resource management and
controls
will help pave the way to success in the
cloud
early on we had a few days of pain with
costs that spiraled out of control
at the top of our do-overs list would be
to implement project budgeting
and or cross-spike detection even
earlier than we did
where possible utilize preemptable
machines
and for long term consistent usage that
would otherwise be on demand
it may be worth it to make a one year or
three year commitment
finally there are many different ways to
optimize costs in the cloud
cost optimizations vary with level of
effort and the cost saving impact
so prioritize accordingly now i'll hand
it back to pathetique
thank you
thanks scott for taking us through that
transformative journey of openx
it doesn't matter if you are a startup
or a hundred year old enterprise
process and optimization tips shared in
this session
and by scott can be leveraged across all
types of customers
if you still need help engage google
cloud professional services
to jumpstart your cost performance
journey